l'album de angélique kidjo célia est
nommé pour le meilleur album de musiques
du monde aux prochaines victoires de la
musique
donc on a bon espoir après le g il
janvier alors je voulais partager cette
joie avec vous et puis vous dire à quel
point ça nous amusait cher parce que
tony allen le batteur de cet album et
qui a inventé l'afrobeat fela et qui m'a
beaucoup inspiré sur ce projet vient de
nous quitter la semaine dernière donc ça
serait un bel hommage qu'on pouvait lui
rendre
en remportant cette victoire en
attendant j'espère rejoindre la
martinique très vite et fêter tous qui a
fêté avec vous prenez bien soin de vous
restez bien confiné qu'on se retrouvent
pour fêter ça babin